I I'm going to talk about functions of
machine learning therapy the new or
improved in version 11
I will talk about image identify
classify and predictable improves a new
function to the feature extraction some
improvement in domain of clustering a
new function to do interpreter bommali
and a function to do by is an
optimization so imagine notify is doing
object classification on images so the
idea is to try to figure out what is the
main object in an image thus 10,000
possible object that it can recognize
and it has been trained on 10 million
images using a deep neural network and
you can see that on this image I
recognized it was a gray wolf and you
can also do things such as specifying if
you want answer to be specific or not so
let's Pacific it will say it's k9 and do
other things like this so classifying
predict have been improved in various
ways and I will show you example of this
the first one is direct consequence of
imagine on if I we've been able to use
the technology we magnify and put it
into classify and this allows us to
train a classifier on images so to
recognize what is the main objects in
images with a very small amount of
images yet with very good accuracy for
example here there's four classes that
we might want to recognize and only
eight images in each of this class and
let's run classify on this data set and
it would create a classifier function so
in area and now we can use this
classifier function on imagine that were
not in the data set and you see
recognize at this word girlfiend is the
center of this dragon and this is a
unicorn and this is a big improvement
compared to the previous version of
classify when you need very large number
of images to obtain
similar performance can tell you that
this classifier as an accuracy of about
90% for this task another improvement of
classify and predicts is ability to
Endel new data type and also mix data
type for example here I'm going to try
to train a classifier with four examples
and each of these as an example as three
features the first feature is an image
the second one is a sequence of token
and the last one is a date and you can
see that it returns a classifier
function and we can check with classify
the information that the features have
been interpreted correctly and the
classifier can take a new example to
figure out what the class is finally new
method have been added and it shows an
example of the Gaussian process method
which is a method for predict that is
very good for small data set so here is
the very small data set and I'm going to
predict this data with a mitigation
process this outputs a Pareto function
and just for you to visualize what is
this method current process I will show
on a plot the data in red along with the
prediction line in blue and in gray you
can see the confidence interval I will
not talk about feature extraction which
is a function to learn feature
extractions from data and feature
extractors are function that can
transform data values type of data into
numerical vectors essentially under the
hood what happens is that we have built
in feature extractor for various type of
data and we also use dimensionality
reduction so as you can imagine this
function is useful for most machine
learning application classification
prediction clustering but I will just
present one example about using feature
extraction to define the
stands in some space where distance are
not usually defined and doing a search
system thanks to things to this so for
example here I have a list of images
that are dogs and I will use feature
extraction on data set it will output
feature extract or function and then I
can use this feature extraction function
on your data for example this is one dog
of data set and you can see the
transform on this image into vector of
numerical values and this vector
captured a lot about the semantics of
this image so what we can do is compute
distances in this feature vector space
in order to have a distance that is that
is good to capture semantic features and
to show that I will create a nearest
function in the feature space and here
is a function nearest dog that will
basically take an image compute the
pictures find which are the nearest
element in the original data set and
grab the picture so in that case there
is a dog that is not in that asset and
we'll see which dog in this data set is
the closest to this dog according to our
created distance and here is closest one
and we can try for a new dog and another
one I will not talk about new function
in domain of clustering one of them is a
cluster classify so the goal of cluster
classify is to output a classifier from
unlabeled data for example here we use a
data set of the Old Faithful that I set
and what we want to do is to try to find
the clusters in data set and I'll put a
classifier that is able to classify a
new example in one of each of these
cluster so for that we just use cluster
classify on
that I said and here is a classifier
function that rustic as if I found and
we can visualize what clustering
inclusive classify found by gathering
the the classified data by their labels
and here are the two clusters the other
function is clustering tree which is
very different from cluster classifying
in the sense that is doing a article
clustering so in order to demonstrate
that I will grab some molecules from
chemical data and I will get some of
their properties as well as their
formulas and what I will do is that I
will use cluttering tree to find a year
called clustering of the the formulas
based on the properties the formulas
here are just the labels and here it was
clustering tree found and actually you
can see that molecule that have similar
formulas happen to be nearby
you know under the yo-yo clustering
based on the other properties okay I
will not talk about interpreter ball
modeling which means that what we so
before with classify predict and and
other functions is many about solving
tasks but without understanding what
model is doing underneath so I will show
to function fine formula and fine
distribution where the goal is is not
necessarily to solve the task as good as
we can but to to have a model that we
can understand and interpret so the
first one is fine formula which is
simply automatic curve fitting so to
show how it works I will grab
temperature of rooms in the last ten
years and actually you can you can see
them and you can see that it has this
sort of paired behavior so we will see
if
and formula can figure that out so to
use it you just do fine formula with the
data in the first argument and this will
be the variable of the other formula and
find formula try it values by these
things and end ups with this quite
simple formula and here is the fit of
the formula and the original data so
this function will not necessarily find
something because if there's something
that is too complicated
it just won't manage to find a simple
formula so so again the goal is not to
use it as predict but our goal is really
if there is a simple formula please find
it and tell me which one it is
you came and on a similar idea there is
a function called fine distributions
where in that case the goal is to find a
distribution a simple symbolic
distribution so here I extracted the
word counts in the Constitution so
there's one word that has been seen 142
times another 186 times but actually
most of them have been seen just once
and in order to know the distribution of
this dataset you could just plot a
histogram but you can also use find
distribution and to see if there exists
a simple distribution that can account
for false data set and you see that
apparently there is a distribution with
the parameter of 1.03 and here you can
see the histogram and the fitted
distribution side-by-side I will now
talk about bison optimization which is
an experimental function that is not
really a machine learning function it's
actually an optimization function but it
uses machine learning to do optimization
in more detail it used predict to model
with the objective function and do
educated guess about where the function
should be queried next and so this
should be used on a particular type of
objective function
mostly when the function is slow to
evaluate and when the function as a
small number of fireballs so typically
it's each time you do an optimization by
hand if you have ever been trying
various parameters and looking at number
and trying to optimize this number by
hand then this means that biasing
optimisation is probably the good tool
to do that instead of yourself so I will
show a classic example by the
optimization which is about finding the
iPad parameters
of a machine learning model so we try to
find the upper parameters of a
classifier with a method support vector
machine so the parameters here okay and
here is our objective function so you
can see that inside this object is
function to this four via bones we will
train a classifier and then we'll
measure how good it is classifier on a
test set and training set and the test
set are taken from the Titanic data set
okay so let's load data set let's
evaluate the loss function and here I
define the region that this parameter
can take and now I can run the function
by the minimization to minimize this
loss function in this region and as you
see takes a bit of time because each
training might take up to one second and
that's why we use biasing optimization
because otherwise you would do that by
hand so okay it's over and it is the
optimal configuration that bias
intimidation found finally I will
mention a very important addition to the
machine learning domain in Mathematica
which is a neural network framework it
is a very powerful framework in order to
Train deepen your network on CPUs on
GPUs and I won't talk about it
further because it is a topic of the
next presentation thank you